ROD. I WANT TO RUN YOU THROUGH
YOUR TOP FIVE HEADLINES
FROM YESTERDAY. WE ASKED YOU
FOR YOUR BIGGEST HEADLINES,
LEAVING SUNDAY, LEAVING MONDAY
NUMBER FIVE, THAT YOU GAVE US
THE NFC WEST. YOU SAID IT WILL
WOULD YOU SEE WHO IMPRESSED?
YOU
PARTICULAR?
WELL.ALL OF ALL THE THINGS
IMPRESSED ME, BUT I WOULD SAY
ARIZONA
NUMBER ONE BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT
WHAT THEY DID ON A DEFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE BALL ISAIAH
SIMMONS. HE HAD NINE TACKLES
TO PASS BREAKUPS
INTERCEPTION. HE WAS ALL OVER
THE PLACE. WE KNOW HIM
TRADITIONALLY AS A PHYSICAL
FREAK, NOW HE'S STARTING TO
LEARN THE GAME MENTALLY AND
YOU STARTING TO SEE HIM GO OUT
THERE AND JUST PLAY BALL
CHANDLER, JONES WAS ABSOLUTELY
OUTSTANDING
FORM COLUMN MARIE. HE LOOKS
LIKE HE'S PLAYING WITH
CONFIDENCE.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S ENGAGED
WITH HIS TEAMMATES BECAUSE
LAST YEAR
YEAR I CRITICIZE
THEM FROM BEING IF
THINGS WEREN'T GOING RIGHT
FORM, THEN HE WOULD POP OUT ON
THE SIDELINES. NOW, YOU SEE
HIM MORE ENGAGED WITH HIS
TEAMMATES, AND THAT JUST SHOWS
TO ME
A SIGN OF MATURITY. I LIKE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING ON THAT
SIDE OF THE
BALL.
I
WANT TO RIP THROUGH SOME OF
THESE CHANDLER JONES
HIGHLIGHTS AND WHAT HE WAS
DOING TO TAILOR THE LAWN.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO BACK AND
WATCH THE FIRST HALF OF THAT
GAME,
HE JUST HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO TIME
TANNEHILL. YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT AJ BROWN, YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT JULIO JONES AND
THESE NEW WEAPONS THAT HE HAS
DOWN THE FIELD.
SOMETIMES IT WAS LIKE TAYLOR
LEWAN DIDN'T EVEN GET A
HANDLE. LOOK AT HIM RIGHT
THERE, DIDN'T GET A HAND ON
ME. CHANDLER JONES. JUST NOW.
I'M GOING TO SAY TO HIS RIGHT
OFF IN THE SECOND. HE PUTS
THEM ON THEM. HE'S CRUISING BY
I'M ROD. WILL YOU SEE
IT?
AND LET ME SAY THIS,
IF YOU'RE MIKE, VRABEL, AND
YOU KNOW THAT YOUR LEFT TACKLE
IS COMING OFF AN ACL AND
YOU GOT ONE OF THE PREMIER
PASS RUSH AS ONE OF THE TOP
FIVE PASS RUSHERS. WHY THE
HECK DON'T YOU SLIDE A TIGHT
END OVER THERE? WHY DON'T YOU
GO GET A RUNNING BACK TO CHIP
ON THEM? SEE? MY BRAVE? OH, HE
DID A POOR JOB, AND THAT'S MY
FORMER TEAMMATE, BUT HE DID A
POOR JOB OF
OF
PREPARING HIS TEAM.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT ONE
GUY SHOULD HAVE FIVE SACKS
AGAINST ANOTHER GUY. YOU KNOW,
THAT YOUR LEFT TACKLES COMING
OFF A MAJOR INJURY AND YOU
DON'T. I
DAY, MAN, YOU CAN'T DO THAT AS
A COACH. YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. THAT'S
WHAT YOU GET PAID
FOR.
IN COLOUR MURRAY LOOKS FREAKY
TO. I MEAN, I JUST THINK THAT
THIS ARIZONA TEAM IS GOING TO
BE REALLY GOOD
EYE COLLOR. SOMETIMES IS
BUYING HIMSELF ABOUT 10
SECONDS TO THROW
AND NOBODY COULD EVEN GET A
HAND ON. IT WAS TWO-HAND
TOUCH. HE WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
DOWN. HE COULD RUN TO THE
RIGHT TO THE LEFT. I MEAN I'M
THINKING ABOUT THAT NAKED
BOOTLEG. THEY DID DOWN ON THE
GOAL LINE WITH THEM WHERE HE
FAKES THE HANDOFF. HE'S IN
HE'S IN THE END ZONE OVER BY
THE PYLON BEFORE THE
DBE'S BEFORE THE EDGE CONTAIN
PLAYER EVEN REALIZE THAT IT
WAS A BOOTLEG. HE IS THAT
KIND OF CREEPY FAST
CAN'T SEE AND HE DOES THINGS.
HE'S RUNNING FOR, YOU KNOW,
EIGHT YARD FIRST DOWN
BEFORE THE DBZ, EVEN THOUGH
THEY TOOK OFF RUNNING. SO HE
HAS SOME ELITE SPEED BACK
THERE AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION
THAT LIKE WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER. YOU SEE WITH
LAMAR YOU SEE IT WITH MIKE
VICK. I DON'T KNOW WHO ELSE IS
IN THAT CLASS. THIS GET TO
YOUR FOURTH HEADLINE RIDE.
RODNEY SAID, LET ME SAY THIS.
HOLD ON. YES.
HOLD ON. HOLD ON. LET'S LET'S
TALK ABOUT THE TITANS.
TITANS NEED TO STOP ALL THAT.
TALK ABOUT THE SUPER BOWL.
OKAY,
ONE PERSON AND I
EVEN SAID THIS BEFORE.
OR LIKE JULIO COMES OVER
JULIO. MRS. ALVAREZ OUT OF
TIME IN PRACTICE. HE MISSES
GAMES. SO FOR THEM TO SAY,
WELL, JULIO'S AREN'T MISSING
PIECE.
NOW. HE HAD THREE CATCHES. HE
HAD THREE CATCHES. HOW DO YOU
BRING A GUY OVER? PAY HIM THE
TYPE OF MONEY THAT YOU
PAYING HIM AND HE HAS THREE
CATCHES.
I JUST THINK THAT THE LOSS OF
ARTHUR SMITH THAT NO ONE'S
TALKING ABOUT, OKAY.
FORMER OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR.
HE NOW HE'S THE HEAD COACH OF
THE ATLANTA FALCONS TO ME. I
THINK THAT'S A BIG ONE. I
THINK THE PERSON IS GOING TO
BE
MOST AFFECTED BY
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
DERRICK HENRY. YOU LOOK AT
DEREK HENRY AND THAT
RUN GAME.
IT WAS NOTHING LIKE ARTHUR
SMITH WHEN HE WAS THERE. SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING FOR US
TO WATCH OUT IN THE FUTURE.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
YEAH, NO. NO, I'M HE TIME. YOU
WANT MAN ANYTIME YOU WANT BUT
THAT WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS
PUTTING, YOU KNOW, SEVEN EIGHT
MAN BOXES DOWN THERE
AUTUMN. AND THEY COULDN'T
PASS. PROTECT LIKE THERE'S DO
IT EVERY WEEK. THEY DO IT
EVERY WEEK. THEY WERE
THEY DO, THEY WERE TRUSTING
TAYLOR LAWAND TO GO BLOCK,
CHANDLER JONES, BUT IF YOU
TALK TO OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
ABOUT WHO'S SOME OF THE MOST
UNDERRATED
PAST ROACHES IN THE LEAGUE,
THE NAME THAT KEEPS GETTING
BROUGHT UP IS CHANDLER
JONES, CHANDLER JONES. I
ALWAYS HEAR THAT NAME
A CONTRACT YEAR NOW
FOR HIM. HE WANTS TO BE PAID.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ON
FOOTBALL NIGHT IN AMERICA.
HE WANTS TO BE PAID LIKE THE
BEST, RIGHT? HE WANTS TO BE
PAID LIKE THE ELITES LIKE THE
WATTS. HE WANTS TO GO GET THAT
HUNTER MILLIE PLUS AND SO
HE'S GONNA GO TAKE OVER
FOOTBALL GAME. I WANT TO GET
THROUGH YOUR HEADLINES. DO
NUMBER FOUR. YOU SAID WINSTON,
AND THE SAINTS THIS
OFFENSE IS GOING DEEP
WITH THAT ROD. WHO DO YOU
LIKE? WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT
THE SAINTS OFFENSE? NOW THAT
YOU GO FROM BREEZE TO
TO WINSTON?
WELL, I LOOK DREW BREES WAS
GREAT. NO QUESTION ABOUT
HIS LEADERSHIP. HIS
CONSISTENCY. EVERYTHING THAT
HE'S DONE IS ACCURACY. ALL
THAT IS GREAT. BUT NOW THEY
HAVE A QUARTERBACK THAT CAN
PUSH THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD
WINSTON CAN THROW THAT THING
DOWN THE FIELD AND SEAN
PAYTON, YOU BETTER BELIEVE
THAT HE WANTS TO OPEN UP THAT
OFFENSE. YOU GOT ALVIN
KAMARA WHO'S ABSOLUTELY
OUTSTANDING AND CATCH THE BALL
OUT OF THE BACKFIELD. YOU GOT
A YOUNG TIGHT END THAT'S GOING
UP, MAKING PLAYS.
THAT'S THE ONE THING THAT
WINSTON CAN DO. HE CAN PUSH
THE BALL DOWN THERE. THE GUYS
LIKE HIM. HE'S A FUNNY GUY,
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO PLAYING
FOOTBALL,
SEAN PAYTON IS GOING TO
TIGHTEN HIM UP. HE'S NOT GOING
TO TURN THE BALL OVER, AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
LOT MORE
OF THIS. THEY'RE HAVING A
BUNCH OF FUN
PLAYING WITH JAMEIS WINSTON
BECAUSE NOW THEY KNOW THEY CAN
GET THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD.
HE'S GOING TO BE ACCURATE AND
HE'S NOT TURNING THE BALL OVER
AND THIS IS WHAT WE EXPECT
FROM.
HIM.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE PACKERS
A LITTLE BIT AS YOU SEE
DEONTE HARRIS GO INTO THE END
ZONE. HE WAS OPEN THE ENTIRE
GAME FOR THE SAINTS, BUT
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE PACKERS.
I THINK THIS OFFSEASON
DRAMA HAS TRICKLED NOW INTO
THE REGULAR SEASON,
YOU CAN'T JUST SKIP THROUGH
ALL THE OTAS, ALL THE
OFFSEASON PROGRAMS HAVE ALL
THIS DRAMA GOING ON, AND IT
DOESN'T AFFECT YOU BY THE TIME
YOU GET TO WEEK ONE,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO TAKE THE PRESEASON
SERIOUSLY. AND YOU THINK BACK
TO LAST YEAR, PICK
JORDAN LOVE AARON RODGERS
GOES, YOU KNOW,
FOUR FINGERS, DEEP ON THE
WHISKEY.
SELF RIGHT FOR THE REGULAR
SEASON. I THINK HE
WAS TICKED OFF WHICH HUGE
OH, SO, HE'S IN THE BEST SHAPE
THAT WE'VE SEEN HIM IN IN HIS
CAREER AND HE PLAYED THE BEST
SEASON WE'VE EVER SEEN
THIS OFFSEASON HAWAII.
HE'S DATING A MOVIE STAR. HE'S
LIVE IN THAT TYPE OF LIFESTYLE
AND HE'S PLAYING THAT
TYPE OF FOOTBALL. SO I THINK
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE GREEN BAY PACKERS,
GET YOU TO HEADLINE NUMBER
THREE, DOLPHINS.
TIRED OF THE BILLS AND THE
PATRIOTS. TALK THE MIAMI
DOLPHINS. WHAT DO YOU SEE FROM
YESTERDAY IN THE WIND
WIND ROD?
WELL, I'LL TELL YOU IS BRIAN
FLORES, DID A WONDERFUL JOB. I
THOUGHT HIS DEFENSIVE GAME
PLAN WAS WAS WAS
GOOD.
I THOUGHT HE'D REALLY DID A
GOOD JOB OF PREPARING HIS
TEAM IS TEAM. WENT ON THE
ROAD. THIS TEAM IS A TEAM
THAT WON TEN GAMES LAST YEAR
THEY WENT ON THE ROAD. THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE SEASON WOULD
HAVE QUARTERBACK THAT
EVERYBODY WAS UNSURE ABOUT AND
THEY BEAT THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS. THEY BEAT THE
PATRIOTS. HE BEAT, BILL
BELICHICK'S, STRAIGHT UP
MAN-TO-MAN.
AND I THINK THAT WAS A
MESSAGE, NOT ONLY TO THE NEW
ENGLAND PATRIOTS, BUT IT WAS A
MESSAGE TO THE
BUFFALO BILLS. THAT BRIAN
FLOOR IS FEEL LIKE HE CAN WIN
THIS.
HE CAN WIN THIS DIVISION. THEY
HAVE THE DEFENSE. THEY HAVE
SOME PAST CATCHES DEVANTE,
PARKER,
JALEN WADDLE.
I BET THEY GOT THREE REALLY
GOOD
TIGHT ENDS. THEY GOT A GOOD
OFFENSIVE LINE. THEY GOT
A DEFINITELY A REALLY GOOD
DEFENSE.
HE FEELS LIKE HEY, NOBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT HIS FINE.
WE'LL JUST CONTINUE TO CREEP
UP ON ON ON THESE GUYS.
WHETHER IT'S NEW ENGLAND,
WEATHER. IT'S BUFFALO BILLS,
AND WE KNOW THE JETS THINK.
SO.
THE JETS DO STILL STINK, WHICH
I WAS ACTUALLY KIND OF
SURPRISED BY
WITH THE PATRIOTS THOUGH.
WHEN THE PATRIOTS STARTED
TRUSTING MAC JONES IN THIS
GAME. I FELT LIKE THEY TRUSTED
MAC JONES MORE IN THE
PRESEASON,
THEN THEY TRUSTED HIM IN THE
GAME YESTERDAY AND THE GAME
TWO DAYS AGO NOW AND EVEN KNOW
WHAT DAY IT IS ANYMORE,
BUT THEN THEY DID ON SUNDAY
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE THEY
WERE THEY WERE IN THE FIRST
HALF. IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE
RUNNING GAME.
THEY'RE WAITING TILL THEY HAVE
TO THROW BEFORE THEY DO THROW
IN THE SECOND HALF WHEN THEY
CAME OUT AND JUST TRUST THEM.
I DON'T, I DON'T THINK THIS IS
AN AVERAGE ROOKIE. I THINK YOU
PICKED
HIM.
HE'S NOT AN AVERAGE ROOKIE
BECAUSE YOU PLAYED FOR BILL
BELICHICK'S, BROTHER AND NICK
SABAN AT ALABAMA. SO HE KNEW
EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM. HE
THINKS LIKE A VET. HE PLAYS
LIKE A VET. YOU SAW THAT IN
THE PRESEASON. HE'S STEPPING
UP THROUGH THE POCKET. HE'S
DOING THINGS HONESTLY THAT WE
USED TO SEE
TOM BRADY DO PLAYING IN A NEW
ENGLAND OFFENSE, STEPPING UP
THROUGH AND BUY AN EXTRA TIME
BUT ALWAYS COMING
FORWARD, NOT DROPPING BACK,
NOT DOING ROOKIE THINGS, BACK
THERE AND WHEN THEY LET HIM
THROW IN THE SECOND HALF, I
THOUGHT, MAC JONES LOOKED
AWESOME. I REALLY THOUGHT HE
LOOKED LIKE HE COULD HAVE IF
HE WAS DOING THAT THE WHOLE
GAME. I
I'VE OBVIOUSLY HAD A FUMBLE AT
THE VERY END TO WHICH JUST
GAVE IT AWAY.
YEAH, WHEN A COACH IS VERY
CONSERVATIVE AND HE SEEMS
NERVOUS WITH THE PLAYER, THEN
THAT MAKES THE PLAYER NERVOUS.
AND TO ME IF THEY
LIKE, YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT IN
THE VERY FIRST GAME OF THE
PRESEASON. THEY LET HIM COME
OUT. NO HUDDLE, AND
AND, AND IT WAS, IT WAS FINE.
HE WAS DINKING AND DUNKING, HE
WAS PASSING THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD AND IN ALL OF A SUDDEN.
YES. I MEAN SUNDAY,
WE SAW SOME UNCHARACTERISTIC
MISTAKES BY THE PATRIOTS
PENALTIES TWO FUMBLES. I MEAN,
DANNY HARRISON AND POSITION
FOR THEM TO KICK THE
GAME-WINNING
FIELD GOAL.
AND HE FUMBLES THE BALL. I'VE
SEEN BELICHICK, CUT PEOPLE
FOR
FUMBLING THE BALL. REMIND A
STEPHEN SAID HE GOT BURIED ON
THE DEPTH CHART ONCE HE
FUMBLED SO THESE ARE
UNCHARACTERISTIC THINGS. YOU
KNOW, THAT THAT HAPPENED TO
THE PATRONS AND I LOOK AT
THEIR DEFENSIVE FRONT SEVEN,
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE STOUT,
WHICH IS REALLY SUPPOSED TO BE
THE STRENGTH OF THEIR TEAM
AND IT JUST IT WAS AVERAGE.
IT WASN'T VERY GOOD.
I JUST DIDN'T SEE THE
CONSISTENT PRESSURE. I DIDN'T
SEE HIM STOPPING THE RUN. I
DIDN'T SEE THOSE GUYS FLYING
DOWN AND LOOK REALLY W
ENERGETIC AND
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
A FASTER MORE ATHLETIC
DEFENSE. I WAS JUST REALLY,
REALLY STUNNED BY THE
PATRIOTS FRONT
SEVEN.
IT RIGHT. LET'S GET YOU TO
YOUR SECOND HEADLINE. HERE.
WILL GO FROM THE PATRIOTS TO
THE CHIEFS. NOW, THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS. YOU SAID
THE CHIEFS ARE A PROBLEM IN
THE AFC THAT'S BEEN TRUE FOR A
MINUTE. NOW, HOW DO THEY
REMAIN A PROBLEM?
THEY'RE PLAYING AGAINST THE
BROWNS?
I MEAN, YOU TALK ABOUT PATRICK
MAHOMES THIS ENTIRE OFFICE.
ALL HE EVER TALKED ABOUT IS
HOW MOTIVATED IS HE'S
TALKED ABOUT. WE WANT TO GO 20
AND KNOW. THIS GUY IS
TICKED OFF BECAUSE
THE EMBARRASSMENT, WHICH HE
SUFFERED IN THE SUPER BOWL AND
TRUST ME. HE KNOWS
WHAT TAMPA BAY WAS SAYING ALL
THOSE SMART COMMENTS AND SAW
THEM CELEBRATING ON THE SUPER
BOWL ON THE FIELD AT
HOME
AND HE'S TICKED OFF AND YOU
LOOK AT THIS OFFENSIVE LINE.
THESE YOUNG GUYS PLAYED
OUTSTANDING,
YOU KNOW, THEY PLAYED
YOU KNOW, AND IF YOU PROTECT
OUTSTANDING,
PATRICK MAHOMES WITH THAT RUN
YOU KNOW, AND IF YOU PROTECT
GAME AND
PATRICK MAHOMES WITH THAT RUN
WITH TRAVIS,
GAME AND
KELSEY
WITH TRAVIS,
TYREKE HILL.
KELSEY
AND LET ME JUST SAY THIS JOE
TYREKE HILL.
WOODS DID A TERRIBLE JOB
AND LET ME JUST SAY THIS JOE
OF DEFENDING, TYREKE
WOODS DID A TERRIBLE JOB
TYREKE HILL. YOU CAN'T TREAT
OF DEFENDING, TYREKE
HIM LIKE HE'S AN ORDINARY
TYREKE HILL. YOU CAN'T TREAT
WIDE RECEIVER. HE'S NOT HE'S
HIM LIKE HE'S AN ORDINARY
ONE OF THE TOP TWO OR THREE
WIDE RECEIVER. HE'S NOT HE'S
WIDE RECEIVERS IN ALL OF
ONE OF THE TOP TWO OR THREE
FOOTBALL. YOU HAVE TO
WIDE RECEIVERS IN ALL OF
DOUBLE-TEAM THIS GUY. THERE'S
FOOTBALL. YOU HAVE TO
NO REASON BY ONE CORNER
DOUBLE-TEAM THIS GUY. THERE'S
BACK. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
NO REASON BY ONE CORNER
ONE
BACK. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
QUARTERBACK IN THE NATIONAL
ONE
FOOTBALL LEAGUE. THAT COULD
QUARTERBACK IN THE NATIONAL
DEFEND THIS GUY,
FOOTBALL LEAGUE. THAT COULD
THE ENTIRE GAME, YOU HAVE TO
DEFEND THIS GUY,
DOUBLE TEAM. YOU HAVE TO
THE ENTIRE GAME, YOU HAVE TO
SWITCH UP PLACE. A MAN
DOUBLE TEAM. YOU HAVE TO
PLAY SOME ZONE
SWITCH UP PLACE. A MAN
JAM OFF THE LINE.
PLAY SOME ZONE
FOR IMAGE. HE IS SO FAST. AND
JAM OFF THE LINE.
SO
FOR IMAGE. HE IS SO FAST. AND
DYNAMIC. WHAT SENSE DOES IT
SO
MAKE IF YOU PLAY EIGHT YARDS
DYNAMIC. WHAT SENSE DOES IT
OFF OF THEM, BUT YOU NEVER
MAKE IF YOU PLAY EIGHT YARDS
TOUCH HIM WHEN HE COMES OFF
OFF OF THEM, BUT YOU NEVER
THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE. I JUST
TOUCH HIM WHEN HE COMES OFF
NEVER UNDERSTOOD THIS
THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE. I JUST
PHILOSOPHY. THEN YOU HAVE
NEVER UNDERSTOOD THIS
TRAVIS KELCE WHO'S ATHLETIC?
PHILOSOPHY. THEN YOU HAVE
SO WHEN THEY PLAYED A
TRAVIS KELCE WHO'S ATHLETIC?
BALTIMORE RAVENS THIS WEEK,
SO WHEN THEY PLAYED A
WHAT DOES MARLIN? HUMPHREY DO,
BALTIMORE RAVENS THIS WEEK,
DO? DOES HE DOUBLE TEAM?
WHAT DOES MARLIN? HUMPHREY DO,
TEAM TIRE? DOES HE COVER
DO? DOES HE DOUBLE TEAM?
TYREKE
TEAM TIRE? DOES HE COVER
HILL,
TYREKE
DOESN'T COVER, TRAVIS
HILL,
KELCE? THAT'S GOING TO BE A
DOESN'T COVER, TRAVIS
PROBLEM. SO THEY HAVE TO
KELCE? THAT'S GOING TO BE A
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY'RE GOING
PROBLEM. SO THEY HAVE TO
TO DO WITH THEIR BEST
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY'RE GOING
CORNERBACK AND HOW HE COULD
TO DO WITH THEIR BEST
DEFEND
CORNERBACK AND HOW HE COULD
TWO GUYS BECAUSE
DEFEND
CUZ THERE'S NOBODY ELSE THAT
TWO GUYS BECAUSE
COULD OFFEND
CUZ THERE'S NOBODY ELSE THAT
TYREE KILL OR TRAVIS
COULD OFFEND
KELCE.
TYREE KILL OR TRAVIS
IT'S ABOUT EVERY TIME
KELCE.
TYREE KILL CATCHES, THE BALL,
IT'S ABOUT EVERY TIME
DON'T REALLY MATTER WHERE HE
TYREE KILL CATCHES, THE BALL,
GETS A CATCH. IT JUST FEELS
DON'T REALLY MATTER WHERE HE
LIKE IT, TURNS INTO A PUNT
GETS A CATCH. IT JUST FEELS
RETURN. YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE IT, TURNS INTO A PUNT
HE KIND OF CATCHES IT.
RETURN. YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
HE STOPS LOOKS AROUND FOR A
HE KIND OF CATCHES IT.
SECOND SORT OF
HE STOPS LOOKS AROUND FOR A
EVALUATES WERE THE DEFENDERS
SECOND SORT OF
ARE AND THEN
EVALUATES WERE THE DEFENDERS
HE'S SO LETHAL. AFTER THE
ARE AND THEN
CATCH BEING ABLE TO JUST PICK
HE'S SO LETHAL. AFTER THE
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO AND WHERE
CATCH BEING ABLE TO JUST PICK
HE WANTS TO GO. HE SOMETIMES
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO AND WHERE
HE PICKS UP 10 SOMETIMES 20.
HE WANTS TO GO. HE SOMETIMES
SOMETIMES HE BREAKS IT FOR AN
HE PICKS UP 10 SOMETIMES 20.
80-YARD TOUCHDOWN.
SOMETIMES HE BREAKS IT FOR AN
MAHOMES STARTS GAINING TIME EN
80-YARD TOUCHDOWN.
BACK THERE AND HE STARTS JUST
MAHOMES STARTS GAINING TIME EN
BUYING EXTRA TIME BACK
BACK THERE AND HE STARTS JUST
THERE BEHIND THE
HE IS ALWAYS LETTING
TYREKE. HE'LL JUST GO DEEP.
JUST KEEP RUNNING.
FIND SOME OPEN SPACE DOWN
THERE. AND HOW MANY TIMES DO
WE SEE? JUST LIKE WE DID IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THIS GAME
WHERE MAHOMES FINDS AMIGOS?
SCREW IT TYRESE DOWN THERE
SOMEWHERE AND HE JUST SHUCKS
THAT THING UP AND THOSE TO
JUST HAVE THIS LIKE
TELEPATHIC COMMUNICATION GOING
ON. THEY'D BOTH KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE TO BE AND THESE ARE
THOSE
GAME BREAKING 80
90 YARD TOUCHDOWNS. AND BEFORE
YOU KNOW IT
IT'S A THREE-POINT BALL GAME
AGAIN,
AND THE CHIEFS HAVE GOTTEN
THEMSELVES.
HE'S RIGHT BACK IN IT. THEN
THEY STEAMROLL OVER YOU IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER. THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED. THE BROWNS, HAD THIS
GAME IN THE BAG AND THEY JUST
LET IT SLIP AWAY LATE WITH IT,
A, YOU KNOW, A WIDE OPEN. ONE
OF THOSE SCRAMBLE AROUND DEEP
THE TYREKE FIGURE IT OUT,
TOUCHDOWNS THAT GOT THEM
AGAIN.
LET ME TELL YOU, IF I WAS A
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR. I WOULD
TELL MY, I WOULD PUT MY
SECOND OR THIRD CORNER ON
TYREE KILL. I WOULD, I WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT A SAFETY STAYS
OVER TOP AND I WOULD INVITE
THEM TO RUN THE BALL AND
RUN THE BALL IF YOU WANT TO
RUN THE BALL, 30 40 TIMES
UP AND DOWN THE FIELD. FINE,
AND WE'LL HAVE TO PLAY TOUGH
DEFENSE IN THE RED ZONE, BUT
THERE'S NO WAY I'M LETTING
TYREKE LLL, CATCH, 11 PASSES,
ALMOST 200 YARDS,
EMBARRASS US, AND REALLY OPEN
UP. THINK ABOUT THIS, THOSE
BEAT PLAYS THOSE 70 80,
RDP 70, 80, YARD.
LAYS DOWN THE FIELD. THEY GET
THE ENTIRE
SIDELINE PUMPED UP. THEY GET
THE DEFENSE GOING TO GET THE
SPECIAL TEAMS. GOING TO GET
THE OFFENSE PUMPED UP. SO
THOSE ARE REALLY
DEVASTATING KNEE. YOU THINK
ABOUT BRINGING IN JOHN
JOHNSON? LIKE JOHN. YOU
CAN'T GIVE UP
70-YARD
PASSES IN THE DEEP PART OF THE
FIELD. THAT'S WHY THEY PAID
YOU TO TYPE OF MONEY. THEY
PAID YOU. I JUST,
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHEN I'M WATCHING THIS. LIKE,
HOW DO YOU PUT ONE GUY ON
TYREKE HILL? IT'S JUST, IT'S
JUST
MIND-BOGGLING TO ME.
THEY'RE PROBABLY TOO WORRIED
ABOUT TRAVIS KELCE.
THAT'S GOT TO BE THE ANSWER
RIGHT EYE. HOW DO YOU?
I'M ACTUALLY CURIOUS THAT
ANSWER RODNEY. LIKE WHEN YOU
HAVE
TWO AWESOME PLAYERS ON
AND OFFENSE, TWO GUYS THAT YOU
SHOULD
DOUBLE
ONE'S A TIGHT. END ONE'S JUST
A TRUE SPEEDSTER,
ROADRUNNER TYPE WIDE RECEIVER.
HOW DO YOU DECIDE WHO SHOULD
GET THE EXTRA DEFENDER?
HOW DO YOU EVEN DO IT AT THAT?
WE'VE,
I'LL TELL YOU THIS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WHAT YOU CAN DO AND
THIS IS WHAT WE DID. A LOT OF
WHEN I WAS WITH THE PATRIOTS
WHO ON OUR
BACK TO BACK CHAMPIONSHIPS AND
WE HAD A TINY LIKE A TONY
GONZALEZ. WE WOULD DOUBLE HIM
WITH ME AND A LINEBACKER
AND THEN YOU COULD
DOUBLE A NUMBER ONE, RECEIVER
WITH
THE FREE SAFETY AND OTHER
CORNER. EVERYBODY
ELSE IS MAN-TO-MAN. SO, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE
OTHER GUYS.
CAN
STICK INTO GARTH ONE-ON-ONE,
BUT YEAH, YOU GOT TWO
SAFETIES. YOU COULD DOUBLE
TEAM BOTH THOSE GUYS AND TAKE
THEM AWAY. YOU CAN'T DO IT
EVERY SINGLE PLAY
BUT IN SPECIFIC INSTANCES LIKE
IN A RED ZONE,
WHO DOESN'T DOUBLE TEAM?
TRAVIS KELCE, HOW COULD YOU
HAVE THEM OUT THERE? AND I'M
SITTING THERE YELLING AND
SCREAMING AT THE TELEVISION,
LIKE
DOUBLE TEAM
IS GOD, JAM AND BEAT HIM UP.
JUST DON'T LET HIM FREE
BEHIND THE LINEBACKERS, CATCH
THE BALL AND WALK RIGHT INTO
THE END ZONE. IT'S CRAZY
TO ME.
I LIKE THAT'S THAT'S WHY I
LIKE GETTING YOU BACK TO THOSE
PATRIOTS. THEY GET YOU BACK IN
THERE BECAUSE NOBODY COULD
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEFEND THESE
TWO
PROUDLY. HARRISON WAS A
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR THAT
VERY WELL MAY BE DIFFERENT.
LET'S GET YOU TO YOUR NUMBER
ONE HEADLINE COMING OUT OF
YESTERDAY,
THE TITANS STOP.
ALL THE SUPER BOWL, TALK
IS WHAT YOU SAID ROD.
WHY ARE YOU NOT BELIEVING IN
THE TITANS AFTER WEEK ONE?
JUST SEPTEMBER NOW. COME ON,
MAN.
THE TITANS
LOOK SOFT. THEY DIDN'T LOOK
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT PLAYING
LIKE,
DUDE. THIS IS THE FIRST GAME
IN THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL
YOU COME OUT ANS AND
AND YOU PUT THAT ON THE FIELD.
LIKE LIKE I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED.
MIKE VRABEL.
MIKE? VRABEL IS AN EXCELLENT
COACH. HE WAS AN EXCELLENT
FOOTBALL PLAYER. ALL HE
THOUGHT ALL HE TALKED ABOUT
WAS
PREPARATION AND WHEN WE
PREPARE DOING A WEEK, HE WOULD
ASK MORE QUESTIONS THAN ANYONE
AND IT'S JUST SURPRISE ME THAT
ONE THING. I HADN'T REALLY
SEEN FROM MIKE THAT HIS
TEAM WASN'T.
PRAYER
AND IT JUST FLAT-OUT WASN'T
PREPARED. I WAS JUST REALLY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
TENTH OF THE TENNESSEE, TITANS
ALL THIS
OFFSEASON TALK ABOUT THE SUPER
BOWL AND THIS AND THAT.
MAN, GET YOUR DEFEE RIGHT,
GET TOUGH. LEARN HOW TO BLOCK
CHANDLER JONES BEFORE YOU
START TALKING ALL THAT CRAP
ABOUT
SUPER BOWL.
THEY FELT REALLY PREDICTABLE
OFFENSIVELY YESTERDAY THAT
WATCHING THEM WATCHING THAT
GAME BACK. IT WAS LIKE FIRST
AND SECOND DOWN. YEAH,
THEY'RE IN THIS HEAVY
FORMATION. YEAH, THEY'RE GIVEN
THE VAULT DERRICK HENRY. WE
GOT IT'S JUST WHAT IT FELT
LIKE, FELT LIKE THAT IF WE
GIVE IT TO HIM, 30 TIMES, HE'S
GOING TO BREAK IT OFF AND
WHERE YOU GET
A HUNDRED FIFTY, JUST LIKE WE
DID LAST SEASON.
WE'RE GONNA FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO
GET WIN THIS GAME, AND IT
NEVER HAPPENED
WHEN I THINK THE STRATEGY
SHOULD BE
GET AJ BROWN
GONE EARLIER. GET
JULIO JONES GOING EARLIER. GET
THAT PASSING GAME GOING ON
FIRST AND
2ND DOWN AND THEN
FOURTH QUARTER. IF YOU GET
PREDICTABLE, THEY START
BRINGING THE SAFETY DOWN. THEY
START BRINGING EXTRA
LINE, BACKERS OF SEVEN,
EIGHT, MAN FRONTS THE RUNNING
AGAINST REGULARLY THINKING
THAT HE'S JUST GOING TO BE THE
DIFFERENCE. IT GO. MAKE IT
HAPPEN FOR THEM AND HE WASN'T
ABLE TO DO THAT INSTEAD. HE'S
GETTING STUFFED ONE AND TWO
YARDS IN THE BACKFIELD
ROUTINELY. I THOUGHT
YOU'D PROBABLY HAVE TO GIVE
SOME LOVE TO WHAT ARIZONA WAS
DOING DEFENSIVELY. TALK ABOUT
CHANDLER, JONES, EARLIER,
TALKED ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
THEIR LINEBACKERS AND WHAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO, FLYING
AROUND THE INSIDE. SO
NEW NUMBER NOW. WEARING NUMBER
NINE. IT'S ALL THESE NEW
NUMBERS. WHAT DO YOU THINK ALL
THESE NEW NUMBERS? RONNIE? I
WANTED TO ASK YOU THAT BECAUSE
WHEN I'M WATCHING THIS FILM, I
GOT TO CHECK THE DEPTH CHART
ABOUT A HUNDRED TIMES.
REMEMBER WHO THESE GUYS ARE?
EVERYBODY'S GOT A SINGLE
DIGIT, SOME WEIRD NUMBER. I
KNOW, TOM BRADY HATED IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK FROM THE
DEFENDERS POINT
OF VIEW?
I THINK THE NFL
ABSOLUTELY CREATED A MONSTER.
I THINK IT'S THE DUMBEST THING
EVER. I MEAN, NO SINGLE DIGIT
NUMBERS. I WAS ONE OF THOSE
GUYS WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL. I WAS NUMBER THREE AND
I LOVE THE SINGLE DIGIT
NUMBER
AND EVEN IN
WELL IN COLLEGE, I THINK I WAS
NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN. I WAS NUMBER 37,
BUT NOW AS A BROADCASTER,
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE NAMES
AS JUST LIKE TOM TALKED ABOUT
AS A QUARTERBACK. IT'S SO
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHO'S WHO WHERE THEY'RE
PLAYING
AND IT JUST IT MAKES IT A LOT
MORE DIFFICULT, NOT JUST ON
THE BROADCAST,
I THINK THE NFL ABSOLUTELY
CREATED A MONSTER. I THINK
IT'S THE DUMBEST THING EVER. I
MEAN, NO SINGLE DIGIT NUMBERS.